I just had dinner so I am well
fed, and I am ready to do more
SAT problems. So we're on
section seven, on page--
excuse me, maybe I should
drink some more water--
section seven of the
sixth test, on page
733, problem one.
In a certain game, points are
assigned to every word.
Each q, x and z in a word-- it
sounds like Scrabble-- is
worth 5 points.
And all other letters are
worth 1 point each.
So q, x and z are 5 points each,
and the other ones are 1
point each.
What is the sum of the points
assigned to the word exquisite?
Well this is just-- exquisite.
So let's see, which of
these does it have?
It has an x, right?
So that's worth 5 points.
Does it have any
other of these?
No-- well, it has a q, right?
That's worth 5 points.
It doesn't have a z, right?
And so how many one-pointers
are there?
There's 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
So 7 one-pointers.
So that's 7 points, plus 5 plus
5 plus 10 is equal to 17.
So that's B.
So that's really just to make
sure that you don't make
careless mistakes,
that problem.
Next problem.
If you've ever played Scrabble,
that problem would
be a joke for you.
Problem two.
If 2x minus 10 is equal to 20,
then x minus 5 is what?
So the big discovery here is--
you could solve for x, you
could say 2x is equal to 30, x
is equal to 15, and say 15
minus 5 equals 10.
Or you could say, well this is
the same thing as 2 times x
minus 10 is equal to 20, divide
both sides by 2, x
minus 10 is equal to 10.
Oh, sorry, maybe that's why you
shouldn't do it this way.
2 times x minus 5, x minus
5 is equal to 10.
So that's the other way you
could have done it, you just
factor out a 2, you get 2 times
x minus 5 is 20, divide
both sides by 2, you get
x minus 5 is 10.
The other way is obviously
to say 2x minus
10 is equal to 20.
Add 10 to both sides.
2x is equal to 30.
x is equal to 15.
So then x minus 5 is 15 minus
5, which is equal to 10.
I don't know which way might
be faster for you.
This way might-- you have to do
less thinking, and you just
kind of chug through
it, so you can just
kind of speed along.
But this way's a few less steps,
but maybe you might
make a careless mistake
like what I just did.
But anyway, let's move on.
Hopefully, either way you
know how to do it.
Problem three.
I'll do it right here.
If t represents an odd
integer, which of the
following represents
an even integer?
So t is an odd integer.
And we can do this kind of
abstractly, but let's just
pick a number.
Let's just say that t is equal
to-- what's an odd integer?
Well, 3, 3 is an odd integer.
So let's just say t equals 3--
they didn't say, we could have
picked t equals 7, who knows.
So then just go through the
choices and say, well, which
one of those is going to
be an even integer?
Choice A is t plus 2.
Well 3 plus 2 is 5, that is
still odd, so that's not the
right answer.
B, 2t minus 1.
Well that's 6 minus 1,
that's 5, that's odd.
Choice C is 3t minus 2, that's
9 minus 2, which is still 7,
so that's still odd.
Choice D is 3t plus 2,
that's 9 plus 2,
which is equal to 11.
And I'm just saying t is 3.
That's still odd.
So it's probably
going to be E.
5t plus 1, and 15 plus 1
is 16, and that's even.
So that's our answer.
So sometimes I find it easy
if you just pick a number.
The other way is if you are
familiar with even and odd
numbers, you can just say, well,
the only way to go from
an odd to an even number, is you
either have to multiply by
an even soon. number, or
add an odd number.
Those are the only ways you can
go from an odd number to
an even number.
So looking at 5t plus 1, you
could say, well when I
multiply an odd number by an odd
number, I'm going to get
another odd number, right?
So this number is odd.
When I take an odd number
and I add 1 to it,
I get an even number.
So you could say 5t plus
1 is definitely going
to be an even number.
And it worked with the odd
number that we picked for t.
Next problem.
OK, so they drew
a picture here.
So I will draw a picture
here as best as I can.
That's one triangle they drew,
this is the other one.
Looks something like this.
Like that.
And then this-- they say
this is A, B, C.
This is D, E, F.
These sides are 4, 8, and 9.
Now what are they saying?
For the triangles above, the
perimeter of ABC equals the
perimeter of DEF.
OK, it equals that.
If ABC is equilateral, what
is the length of AB?
OK, so it's equilateral,
right?
So let's just say that
AB is equal to x.
Well then, so is BC and AC,
because they told us, this is
an equilateral triangle.
All the sides are equal.
And what is the perimeter
of ABC then?
It's going to be x plus x plus
x, and that's just 3x.
And they say that that's the
same thing as the perimeter of
this triangle.
What's the perimeter
of this triangle?
It's 4 plus 8 plus 9.
So 3x is equal to--what's
12 plus 9-- is 21.
x is equal to 7, and that is
choice C, and we are done.
Next problem.
They have drawn a diagram
here that I will
now attempt to draw.
OK.
And then, let's see they draw
a dividing line, looks like
it's about 1/4 of the circle.
And then they have another one
that's like a little less than
1/4, like that.
Then they have one that's
like that, roughly.
Then it goes like that.
And then they fill in
the values too.
So this is K, it's 15%.
J is 25%.
O-- let's just call
that other, is O.
Other is 20%.
N is 10%.
M is 15% and L is 15%.
And these are sales of jeans in
2001, and the letters are
the brands.
The circle graph above
represents all the jeans that
were sold by a retail
store in 2001
according to their brands.
If the store sold 900 pairs of
jeans-- so this is the total
of all of these, is 900
pairs of jeans.
If the store sold 900 pairs of
jeans other than brands J, K,
L, M and N, how may did
it sell together?
OK, so this isn't the total,
this is the other.
This is essentially this
category, right?
And other is equal to
20% of the total.
And that's what they
want to ask us, how
many did we sell together?
So 20% of the total times t for
total-- let me just say t
for total-- is equal to 900.
And you could also write
this as 1/5.
Or 0.2.
1/5 of the total is
equal to 900.
Multiply both sides by 5.
That cancels out.
So you get t is equal to
4,500 pairs of jeans.
And that is choice E.
Next problem.
Oh, I thought this problem might
apply to this pie graph,
but no, they're talking about
carpets, not jeans.
So I'll do the next problem
in the next video.
I'll see you